à dijon devant la cour d'assises de la
côte-d'or deuxième semaine du procès de
jean marie villemin avec les dépositions
de la famille de l'accusé
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan bruno girodon albert et
monique les grands parents voulaient
sûrement tenter de se réconcilier avec
leur fils en prenant la justice comme
témoin vire aussi aux jurés la
souffrance d'une famille déchirée et là
vous allez vous adresser à des jurés
vous allez un peu leur pose la question
alors si on vous pose la question
qu'allez vous répondent tous les
malheurs connais je reste persuadé que
ma mère c'est quelque chose sur le
corbeau quand jean-marie interroge
monique le ton et cassant sec sans
concession sans amour
ils ne pardonnent pas à ses parents
d'avoir suspects et christine
instruments de cette tension familiale
le corbeau 800 appels en moins de deux
ans jusqu'à 17 coups de fil anonymes par
jour
c'était quelqu'un qui connaissait mes
horaires aujourd'hui encore je ne
comprends pas cet acharnement confie
albert c'était une voix rauque masqué
qui faisait peur
il m'a juré hier ajoute monique qui
pouvait être jaloux de jean marie qui
pouvait en vouloir à albert pour lui
suggérer de se pendre
s'interroge le président en vain qui
pouvait être informés de nos faits et
gestes
le père hésitent à répondre à son fils
puis lui confie du bout des lèvres
michel le frère fâché avec jean-marie
mais très lié avec bernard laroche
michel habite à quelques mètres de chez
ses parents le président s'est fixé deux
objectifs d'abord jugé jean-marie
villemin pour l'assassinât de bernard
laroche mais aussi tenter d'élucider le
mystère de la vologne
ainsi lance-t-il un appel aux témoins
seule la vérité peut aujourd'hui
apporter la paix parler est la seule
chose qui puisse vous aider et nous
aider ultime appel
après neuf ans de silence ou après neuf
ans de mensonges